urgent talks to prevent a possible
russian invasion of ukraine more than
100 thousand russian troops are now
deployed on three sides of the country
and ukrainian forces are preparing for
what could be a major fight secretary of
state anthony blinken is in geneva today
where he met with his russian
counterpart in an effort to stop a
conflict before it begins the u.s is
threatening major economic sanctions
holly williams is in the ukrainian in
the capital holly good morning
good morning here in kiev where about
five thousand miles from america but the
us says this is not simply a regional
dispute far from home instead it's about
protecting democracy and stopping russia
from turning its neighbors into puppet
states
there is no doubt let there be no doubt
at all that if putin makes this choice
russia will pay a heavy price
the u.s is warning russia if it invades
its neighbor ukraine it faces a swift
severe response in the form of sanctions
moscow denies its planning and attack
but new satellite images show the
massive buildup of russian troops and
weaponry along ukraine's border
president biden said a russian incursion
might not use conventional tactics
and paramilitary tactics so-called gray
zone attacks
as an actions by russian soldiers not
wearing russian uniforms
to lower tensions russia's demanding
security guarantees including a rolling
back of nato troops from eastern europe
and a ban on ukraine joining the
alliance those are things the u.s and
its partners say they cannot agree to
and many believe the real motive of
president vladimir putin is to control
russia's neighbours by any means
possible
he he worked like
like a terrorist
with
nuclear weapons but he is still
terrorists he's a terrorist it looks
like that
it's been 30 years since the collapse of
the soviet union and the end of the cold
war but now a european capital is again
looking down the barrel of a russian gun
ukrainians are frightened because it's
not only this threatened for ukraine
it's threatened for all the world
we want a normal life
how we want it
not anybody telling us what to do
the u.s is sending up to 200 million
dollars worth of emergency military aid
to ukraine and has authorized its allies
to transfer american-made anti-tank and
anti-aircraft weapons to ukraine but the
u.s has ruled out sending combat troops
tony
holly williams on the deepening crisis
in ukraine holly thank you very much